[Music]
are you into homeopathic I am yes like
what are we talking we pretty much
really so you don't use you basically if
I'm dying the miracle of Western
medicine I appreciate it and the whole
thing but day to day I try to I care my
dogs I hear myself you get a burn are
you want those people that like puts
yeah I butter on it I put like I use
garlic a lot rosemary olive oil like
that's what I and people call me in the
middle of night like you know on the
crew and go oh man yeah I got this cut
what do I do
then I'll wake up and tell them let's do
that's what what about oh I almost
hearing ginseng is used for everything
like it seems like every homeopathic
cure has ginseng in it it is it guys
love ginseng because there's a it's good
for libido
apparently I mean funny you mentioned it
it's
weird or not weird but there's a there's
a pill there's a pellet experimented its
previous potions and remedies is that
true does ginseng really help a guy
learn down south I am NOT a guy but I've
heard that I had friends when I was
living overseas who took this pill and
it was a ginseng and some other stuff
and it's like viagra but it it doesn't
make your heart palpitate the way look
at all the guys going yeah yeah yeah so
you don't get the rapid palpitations
because it's pumping all the blood down
here right yeah yeah so your heart is
racing
apparently heart is like what's going on
it's all about going is going here and
what it does is it doesn't do that you
get the thing and it it laughs don't get
the thing well you have the thing
it helps the thing do its thing I'm
saying good thing apparently all night
and then and then when you wake up in
the morning the thing is still there and
you can keep going this is still there
it's
I asked you to write this stuff down
honestly that all sounds like a lot of
work to you got to go you don't have
cable channels there are yeah a busy man
I don't need any gin sitting on me and
Eve Angra I got that situation locked
down all right everyone settle down